con la mediación de turquía rusia y
ucrania han asegurado y confirmado hoy
que han intercambiado cerca de unos 300
prisiones de guerra entre ambos lados
para intentar seguir con los esfuerzos
de mediación de turquía que llevan
ocurriendo desde el principio de este
conflicto se trata de cerca de unos 300
estamos hablando de 215 prisioneros que
van al lado ucraniano y 55 que van al
lado ruso lo su cara no son sobre todo a
los miembros del regimiento de arroz y
sus comandantes que resistieron en la
planta de as of talent mariupol durante
el sitio de las tropas rusas también hay
unos 10
combatientes extranjeros que fueron
capturados por los rusos y condenados en
muchos casos a penas de muerte han sido
devueltos a ucrania toda esta gente
según ha afirmado el presidente gordimer
selenski serán mantenidos en turquía
hasta el final de la guerra rusia por su
parte recibirá el magnate y líder de un
partido prorruso ucraniano que fue
detenido hace unos meses después de que
su partido fuese ilegalizado
precisamente por ser profeso este
esfuerzo llega después de meses de
mediación por parte de turquía no sólo
para liberar prisioneros de gran sino
también para intentar frenar el
conflicto recordemos que fue en estambul
se firmó
del cereal y trigo ucraniano en julio de
este mismo año y de hecho putin que se
encontró con erdogán la semana pasada
seguro que erdogán está intentando por
todas las medidas posibles conseguir un
encuentro personal cara a cara entre
sellers y pudding putin aseguró que de
momento no va a pasar pero no descartó
que en un futuro un futuro puede ser
bastante lejanos y que sea posible este
encuentro